why is scripture so harsh on witchcraft
in particular I think it's because
witchcraft
counterfeit what God has given us as a
spiritual people when I come out of
Witchcraft I started to realize that
there were so many similarities that I
was doing on that side that when I
became Christian I realized like wow
this is like the real thing and this is
the opposite one of them was for example
in the Bible we see prophetic acts we
see the anointing oil we see in the
Bible the salt with Prophet elij did a
Propet at we Sal in the water and then
you see that which is you Sal for
cleansing for purification for curses
for cursing people drying all of those
things and then you also have the
rainbow the enemy counters fit
absolutely everything you have also the
blood as I was saying the blood is
powerful for covenants we have the blood
of Jesus